okay welcome back to the rich eisen show
i uh
i have i have affection for this man and
i don't care who knows it
i've known him ever since nfl network
launched 11 years ago way way back when
he was just starting off with the
seattle seahawks he's joining me now
here on colt's cam as the colts are
getting ready to take on the new york
giants on monday night football he is
matthew hasselbeck how are you matthew
what's up rich i'll be with you i'm
thrilled that you are you are here you
are here i don't even know where to
start with you there's so much to
discuss
um you
you have a front row seat to the
quarterback that everybody loves to talk
about being an mvp you're having
you're sitting right there with andrew
luck as he's going through
his first couple of years what what what
can you tell us about andrew that we may
not already know matthew
uh well i think everyone kind of knows
what they what he is i mean he's a great
talent and he's a exactly what you're
looking for when you think about a
franchise quarterback
but he's a young guy and he's growing
and he's making plays and we're winning
games along the way he took his team to
the playoffs that first year in 2012 and
then
again last year won a bunch of games and
you know one more round into the
playoffs and this year expectations are
even higher and and uh and he's been
playing great football he's a leader uh
in the locker room in the community here
obviously replacing a legend and uh you
know it's just fun to be working with
him every day competing with him in
little things on the field off the field
in the weight room in the classroom uh
unfortunately i lose most of the time
but uh but he's great he's a good kid
he's got good friends on this team and
it's good to be with him yeah and i'm
sure you're downloading him with all the
things that that uh that you know and
trying to influence them is he
influencing you with this neckbeard that
i'm looking at right now matthew
yes is that what it is that's exactly
what's going on i gotta tell you
actually last night rich i was at a
charity event and this guy comes up to
me and he's like
tell me all this stuff about germany you
know southern indiana they got this you
know real german community you should go
down there halfway through the
conversation i'm like he thinks on bjorn
werner number 92 uh our german player
from florida state oh he thought i was
bjorn werner oh no i thought that that
andrew luck had some time in germany
himself maybe he thought you were luck
maybe you know because his dad had him
maybe he really thought you were andrew
luck how long did you shine him off like
that aunt
you know
we've gotta we've gotta it was you know
it got to the point in the conversation
where it was too far to like really say
anything and kind of correct him it just
was like i just gonna go with this so we
actually took a picture yeah and so i
don't know when he shows his friends or
whatever he's gonna be like oh this is
me and bjorn werner and uh hopefully
hopefully someone hopefully no one knows
that it wasn't no no no they'll say
that's that that's matthew hasselbeck
that's what they'll say they'll and then
and then that should probably happen to
you that's probably happened to you
before well yes yeah it could ever
happen to you you have no idea matthew
how many times people come up to me i
have gotten in my career i've gotten uh
keith olbermann dan patrick kenny mayne
i've gotten bob lee
people have said i love you and i'm like
you know you know i'm not on espn
anymore and they're like wait a minute
you're not doing outside the lines i'm
like i am not bobbly i've gotten all of
that matt
you know
you know there was a moment there when
when hairstyles were kind of going this
way where you and matt lauer met
for a baby a year or two it was like yum
i don't know what happened when yeah
matt lauer kept going
yeah i think that's rich eisen yeah
yeah no it kept going they kept going
apart baby you're all natural yeah i am
that's true no one can ever take that
away from me uh i'm wondering what you
think of when you're watching monday
night football and you're seeing tony
romo going down like that and uh the
back injury and you know from your
vast experience from playing the
position what you're thinking from your
position
well the first thing i thought i heard
my back in 2008 one thing i know about
when a
low back injury when you hurt your back
the whole world writes you off because
everyone's had a stiff back or a sore
back or knows somebody with a back so
you know he takes a knee somewhere to
that region and he's you know laying
there still for a while and then
everyone all of a sudden is a uh as a
spine surgeon but uh
you know i thought it was gutsy i think
he's having a great year their team's
having a great year it was a gutsy
performance by him coming back out and
i would say probably half the country
expected him to go down and lead him to
victory and then the other half thought
oh hey there's no way he's going to be
able to do this and so uh
it was great television i think it
showed that he's a he's a great
competitor and obviously a huge talent
how many times have you had to talk your
way back into a game so i'm sure you've
attempted that
well i i do think that's an important
thing uh you know for football players
and coaches and players to realize that
hey some of these decisions should be
made by a medical professional should be
made by a doctor but but a doctor
doesn't make those decisions um you know
by himself he really it helps when he
knows the patient knows the player kind
of knows what the injury is and so you
know there is some there's an importance
of uh you know having that you know kind
of player doctor relationship where the
doctor understands if all right is this
the kind of guy that's going to be
honest with me or is this the kind of
guy that's going to lie to me just to
get out on the field and
you know tony's been there there's been
some continuity and it's probably
probably a good relationship there and
him going back into the game i think was
fine it was a safe thing but at the end
of the day that should be the doctor's
call not the coaches call the gm's call
or you know something like that you've
seen that happen in other situations so
uh i thought this was handled well i
stayed up to watch the game i was glad
that i did it was a great game yeah both
teams and uh both quarterbacks played uh
played really really well well i mean it
was there were three quarterbacks in the
game and that's the thing i want to
bring up with you
is that you just never
know
when you might have to be on a stage
like monday night football which you may
you know never know have to be on next
week we saw a geno smith throw three
interceptions right off the bat and for
the jets and suddenly michael vick is in
the game when he doesn't expect to what
is that like
to prepare in your position matthew
well i i have a feeling rich that if
andrew for some reason starts the game
with three interceptions he's going to
stay in the game so
that's one i just have a hunch yeah
right i know
i have a hunch no it is it is you know
transitioning from a starter to a backup
is a lot tougher than people think you
basically you got to be ready to go you
got to be able to play as well if not
better as the starter and with no reps
no practice time and people say well
what does that mean no reps that means
all week like we played the steelers
this past week i was pretending to be
ben roethlisberger the entire week and
really wasn't pretending to be andrew
luck and then when you when you go in
the game you got to pretend to be that
guy and so colt mccoy you know he had a
he had a chance to be the starter all
week in practice prepare
uh with the with the guys he's throwing
to um you know meet with the coaches and
say hey these are these are concepts i
like these are plays i like here's some
things i'd like to run on third down uh
you know those there's a reason they say
practice matters because it does matter
um but at the end of the day if you're
if you're called upon you've got to be
ready to go and you got to get your team
that victory when they need you and then
and then when you're just standing on
the sideline
uh
you never know that you could be just
one tell you what that's that's
you know that and listen if if your guy
gets hurt in the first quarter
okay you know you're kind of loose
second quarter it's a little bit tougher
third quarter okay you've been you got
loose about an hour and a half ago that
fourth quarter man if you've been
standing especially it's like december
or january or something like that you're
freezing you know you're stiff you gotta
you gotta find ways to get loose without
looking like you're trying to get loose
like you don't want the starter kind of
looking over his shoulder like hey why
is my backup warming up right now is he
expected to go in so there's an art to
it man there's there's an art to going
in there and uh looking like you were
ready to go from the from the get-go and
you know i thought brandon whedon went
in and played well uh in the chances
that he got uh was feeding the ball to
their playmakers and then obviously has
a good grasp of what they're trying to
do offensively so i think that made it
for a great game it was good football
last night so if you uh played ben
roethlisberger in practice did that mean
you threw for 522 yards last week
matthew
well it was 523 rich county no no i know
that i should have had you in fantasy if
i'd known that um how are the kids
before i let you go how are the kids
team fantasy football that's the next
thing yeah
kids are great kids are great yeah you
know
oh you're talking about are you talking
about my teammates
your actual children rich so listen to
this yes
listen to this okay we've got our
rookies this year were born in 1993.
that's the same year tom coughlin was my
college coach at boston college
it's amazing it's really really amazing
yeah so you're making pop culture
references they have no idea are they
are you like grandpa
in in the in the locker room is that
what it is
you know you know our guys are pretty
good i'll tell i'll give you a name jack
muhort our our guy from our offensive
lineman from ohio state this year rookie
right young guy but this kid he's got
his pop culture down like you need a
lifeline on 80s movies 80s music
he's a throwback good football player
he knows his stuff that's odd that
someone from ohio state wouldn't be up
don't discriminate just because okay
that's odd that someone from ohio state
wouldn't be up on academics that's
really odd matthew jesus
that's right i just that i just said
that i just said that
this might not be the this this might
not be the right year for you to take
shots uh
no this might not be the right this is
the best year to take shots because i
have no leg to stand on that's the best
time to do it matthew that's the best
time to do it
oh my gosh hey uh listen thank you for
joining i appreciate it hopefully this
this can be not just a one-off as they
say in the business
is that what they say that's right
all right rich thank you you bet take
care good to see you man i'm gonna go
shave i'm gonna go shave my neck don't
do it don't do it to a man matthew
you're a handsome man that's right
brockman thinks you're a handsome man as
always because everybody thinks you're
brothers
thanks chris there you go chris there's
brockman in law with uh matthew
hasselbeck on colt's cam
i love that he's got the necklace
there's no doubt somebody thought he was
andrew luck
the rich eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern
on audience